the hug they've been waiting for for two
months grandfather and granddaughter
reunited during the quarantine we were
desperate now I can't even speak for how
excited I am too excited we have only
seen her with video calls for two months
but it was not the same it couldn't be
the same
Randall avi stylophora when I saw her my
heart stopped it seemed to be a century
since I'd seen her after the longest
lockdown in Europe family visits are
allowed but only if relatives live in
the same region elsewhere the queues
were back at Rome's main determining
station though it's not just tickets but
temperatures being taken obviously after
staying at home for almost 60 days it
feels good I feel good and I feel safe
across Italy more than four million
people were back at work as construction
sites and factories reopened and
restaurants were allowed to sell
takeaway food but taking public
transport is still being discouraged by
government and masks a compulsory when
sharing public spaces and doors funerals
remain limited to 15 people but the
bereaved are able to leave flowers on
the graves of the dead the florists
nearby carefully disinfected with more
than 210,000 reported cases and around
29,000 deaths
Italy's one of the worst affected
countries government leaders fear the
loosening of restrictions will lead to a
resurgence and cases health care workers
are taking extra measures to track
infections isolate clusters and make
sure hospitals aren't overwhelmed again
we're being careful trying not to do too
many things but at least we're finally
outside and breathing some fresh air
families making the most of the sunshine
and parks that have been reopened though
playgrounds remain off-limits
you're happy because finally today they
have opened Fila Borghese after having
closed it for a month and a half
even though obviously my daughter was
disappointed to find the playground all
blocked off
there are many reminders that life isn't
the same with school cinemas and
theaters shut indefinitely but this
ancient country has witnessed plagues
before and recovered Italians just need
to find a balance between staying safe
and embracing their newfound freedom
Alexei O'Brien al-jazeera